it is said that tea was originally
pretty centralized or confined to the
region of yan but the arrival of
Buddhism in the region may have been an
important factor in its wider spread
across China with the arrival of
Buddhism in China through different
Buddhist monks tea quickly became an
important part of religious practice for
these Buddhists uh much like the sufis
the Buddhist monks would often sit in
long periods in meditation which was
tiring very very energy consuming and so
tea which also contains caffeine albeit
not as much as coffee was a useful way
to stay alert and awake during
meditation also a way to recover after a
long meditation session and so much like
with the sufis in southern Arabia tea
became an integral part of Buddhist
practice in China at this time